what's going on reject nation Greg Alba
here I got this sent over to me by quite
a bit of people the flash season 4 hero
reborn promo it's kind of dark back here
for a darker berry
today's patron the day's shoutouts gonna
be for Gareth hood son Yusuf I must give
you a shout-out at the Comic Con trailer
for the flash I forgot
I didn't forget this time Yusuf - run
Barry runs that's the role I won on the
flash TV show is just to be one of those
guys
[Music]
[Music]
years
[Music]
byron
waters fast
[Music]
whoa you know I'm not one who can really
tell this thing but he looks faster in
this trailer actually there was so much
that went on Barry has a beard every
time a guy goes away for a while and a
movie or show they always got to come
back with more facial hair than they had
before and Barry had zero so you know
that Speed Force stressed him out I'm
looking forward to that scene pets in
POV and Cisco's is talking directly to
Barry saying I made you a new suit him
it's me hey somehow you must be going
faster actually I'm excited for that at
one point this could just be Barry with
his hair down then like 15 seconds write
something on the board looks like that's
the Sabbat our Barry doesn't it kind of
looks like in savage art Barry have
eyeliner I mean this bug eye doesn't
Donnie had eyeliner or maybe he's just
turning into sabot are in that moment
I'm not sure I love the moment when
Detective West is shouting iris iris
getting kidnapped man that never gets
old ever I could I wish every episode
was just iris getting kidnapped that
makes for damn good entertaining
repetitive television another going with
the reborn storyline in this I don't
need a [ __ ] you guys and try to be
one of those youtubers who pretends he
knows all the comic books and all that
I'm not super familiar with the reborn
storyline I do love the flash TV show I
had my issues in season three upper
furred season five of arrow and honestly
after the way season three ended I
wasn't too excited for season four but
this trailer got me a little bit more
interested in what's going on I feel
like it's actually gonna do some new
things to take some different directions
got a different kind of billing - at the
beginning of this trailer I was confused
because it didn't look like he had the
flashy dough and he runs into that truck
in the beginning is he naked she just
out in the field naked naked buried that
must that's a good way to get some air
in certain places he did you normally
can't get him YouTube just demonetised
this video let's see if their automated
system can pick up on subtle references
and not just clear-cut words anyway I
like everyone's hair in this trailer
everyone
hair looks good little different it's
always a good mark of a new season
really I'm not sure entirely sure what
everybody got certain people sending
this to me it's a cool trailer it's not
the most exciting one I would have
waited for just a full trailer or the
shows right around the corner I'm
thinking he's doing like reactions or
reviews for those we'll see we'll see
let's see if I'm quick enough oh yeah
and shout out to Yousuf Yousuf we had a
one-on-one Google hangout with your dad
I gotta tell you Yousef you have a
wonderful gem of a father from my
understanding you're the one who
convinced him most recently to get
Netflix your dad had no idea just how
many options there were on Netflix and
I'm sorry but Yusuf the fact that you
guys now have Netflix streaming services
and you didn't have that before I worry
they you look I'm gonna be sincere here
don't get too distracted by Netflix stop
watching narcos you're 12 years old
they're too young to be watching narcos
I mean I saw showgirls when I was 9 ask
Gareth if you could watch that but
narcos is a little bit worse than
showgirls in some areas don't get too
caught up in TV don't become me okay do
something actually interesting with your
life go out there bomb with your family
there's more to life than this and
there's more to life than the computer
there's more to life than television
like make sure to watch the flash when
it comes out October 10 anyway guys
subscribe to the real rejects click that
notification Bell is a weird solo check
out our patreon become a patreon eject
today